[Musique]
alors ce soir ils m'appellent des plans
ura départ estime ans mais j'aimerais
bien vous partager des histoires trois
histoires
trois histoires de femmes
des histoires de toutes les femmes
et histoire de
ce regard que l'on se porte dans les
termes des histoires de ces regards
d'hygiène de l'extérieur et que nous
bouleverse dedans qui nous déstabilise
carrément de commencer par l'histoire de
mariette
mariette est une très belle jeune fille
19 ans étudiante réligieuses second
voire gens de fibres meilleur et candia
son enfant car il a fait du voisin ou
qui ramène à pleurer ou encore
marié à maria qu'on a appris que la
femme cette école ou mariage à fond tu
es bien d'école mariage confins et au
fond d'eux-mêmes tête s'il vous plaît
aux balais dans tous les sens
et marié dans l'amour et marielle
rencontre à la mouche vers des
fonds propres et charmant pardo avec
elle se maria avec un beau mariage un
enfant une belle petite fille une petite
fille parle je vous ai dit que la volée
de vols estimant une petite fille
maria allait quand même à l'épaule avec
un gros ventre saléchan quelle personne
parce que marié et des pousses de canton
et booster les chauffeurs son père
bonnes conditions avant toute façon
vous tolère tout
même jour
maria dégringolade ce piédestal
la prostate bien elle même comme tout le
monde gagnerait faut atteindre le niveau
ce niveau on stigmatise montrait de
finale sans comprendre personne n'a
compris que maria belen de personnes
harry et d'un baiser se retrouver seul
avec le tpir un point de passer c'était
la petite fille la jeune fille qui au
lieu d'aller à l'école et aller faire un
enfant et qui très bas sur l'enfant
partout
marie est apparue à dire mais qui va
prendre ce moment d insulter personne
personne de pointer et horreur qu'on a
déjà utilisé mais qu il n y pas
s'occuper de leurs enfants
j'espère qu'ils en verre finnair
dans la panique et d'autre mais ce n'est
pas l'avis de mariette
mariale à se mettre à l'abri de tous les
regards
à se marier au prix limite y écoute
mariette je vais te redonner l'honneur
je vais aborder en fait tout ce que tu
veux moi je m'en fous je suis déjà un
enfant
il marais selon droit dans un foyer où
elle est elle pas dessus humilié son
mari la trompait et tout ce qui lui
reste les femmes mariées trespass
m'arrête avait peur de second tir est
elle si elle sortait mariette restant
elle soufflé mais elle reste pas parce
que le leur égard que les autres du
porté depuis j'espère il avait fini par
la déstabiliser et ne marquait pas perdu
confiance en des
certains diront qu elle n arrive c'est
une trop petite fille bout comprendre
qu' on peut prendre de décisions que
le choix qu'elle menait le faire et moi
je vous dis
que je vous parlais de la deuxième
personne les uns aux antipodes de
mariette mule traduit dans
les airs d'un bardé de diplômes c'est le
chant de femmes un cassard et donnons
également son parcours ou mais
franchement chapeau mais on admirait pas
les âmes pourquoi parce que
julien de brioude
ensuite il ne prend pas une enfant qui
n'est pas marié tient n'arrivait pas à
stabiliser l'honneur qu'on lui devait la
pression de l'extérieur le regard des
autres le jugement familial tout le
monde à l'église la profession est un
boulet un fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face à tout cela
les gens se marient en fait râler ya
ici
et il est dans un
hallelujah se retrouver du jour au
lendemain dans ce choix il avait de cet
événement si si il n'avait pas que sa
femme du docteur et bien sûr tout prix
la filière en train de chercher à avoir
d'autres diplômes alors dit avec un bts
il dit aimer chez
l'homme que je descendais des pousses
faut que tu veux construire à lui on
regarde toi de moi aux victoires des
infos liesse avait pourtant de quoi
elles s'engageaient à gagny en stand by
the qu'est ce qu'elle voulait devenir ou
se marier vers mes enfants mes liens
dans une mare elle en avait marre
ouverture de tous ces journalistes qui
s'en rendent compte le rugby seule
question à la bouche de qui l'envoyaient
après une réussite un madame s'il vous
plaît quand vous faites poirier vie
professionnelle
mais cette question aujourd'hui 6
[Applaudissements]
sinon qu'à force manon quelques pas
qu'ici garde personnelle envoie quelques
paquets
et a voulu partir les maniaques et c'est
le mode point de vue à 12h tu
l'idée avait commencé comme vous je veux
qu'il ait tué leur pierre tu vas où
comme toi la voix parfois dans le co2 en
est qu'il le fire le support s'en fout
ça s'appelle soyez c'est le feu
je suis sûr que ça va se le dise que
l'amazone doit savoir et écrivaine donc
à la cet animal ce sont des personnages
qui font partie des différents
manuscrits
impressionné va pas l'être mais laissez
moi vous dire que non ces histoires là
sourit elle est la preuve que ces
situations réelles de vous dire ce soit
en province et ce peu comme il est
devant vous c'est moi
parce que je suis d'abord d'essayer la
maison doit s'ammener m a plu et c'est
maintenant que je vous dis bon soir et
je dois les remercier aussi parce que
c'est maintenant que je vais en parler
[Applaudissements]
et pour lequel j'ai répondu ce moment
j'étais humiliée fuel est battu mais je
suis resté parce que je ne voulais pas
qu'on me traite ou mondiaux j'avais une
baie du cassis ou en moyens peu de
mariette un loyer à l'ambition d'aider m
mais j'avais peur de ce que les gens
disaient j'avais peur comme un
traitement je suis resté deux ans je
souriais la
mairie et ont su m je rentre tous les
soirs dormi dans un cercueil quand je
voulais partir j'aurais gardé mon corps
me faisait regarder mon corps me disait
aucun homme de prendre à une femme pour
toi et je suis resté je suis bordel où
je ne vivrai pas mais j'étais là parce
que je voulais comme reagan avait que je
voulais avoir la tête haute même si dans
ma maison la tête n'existait même pas et
puis
un index de
spiritualité méditation contemplative
je vous dit en fait quand le goût mais
tu deviens adp la méditation tout ce que
tu vas dans le
[Applaudissements]
néant j'ai dérapé à quelque chose
à la chrysalide est ce que vous savez ce
que c'est qu'une grisaille
cette étape d'inertie de morts entre la
transformation du ce de la chenille
au papillon en les chenilles on a
l'ambition de devenir quelque chose de
beau
même lieu on meurt on s'était on s'en
faire on oublie tout on n'écoute
personne
ce nous face à soi on se pose des
questions
j'ai analysé je me suis dit j'ai envie
de vie m'a prise a dit je me suis
enfermé
j'ai été amené mon esprit à tous les
jeunes qui viennent de l'extérieur
semble honnête ça va pratiquer mon
chemin je me suis fermé je me suis posé
des question je vous assure c'est
violent et ça m'a sauvé la vie la
première question
arinor que tu détruis j'ai rebondi et
c'est moi mon bonheur se fit reculer à
ce que je pleurais tous les soirs pour
être heureuse mais je n'arrivais même
pas même le nom sur mon bonheur c'est
quoi ton bonheur
c'est d'être marié seulement nous avoir
des hauts fourneaux
c'est moi qu'ils vont oeuvre je vais
être une femme épanouie
je vais être une mère
et j'aimerais dans ce cheminement avoir
un mari bonus
[Applaudissements]
comme ça ça peuple et mentalité là qui
me permet de briller des clubs c'est ma
celui qui va animer dingue mais alors
qu'est ce que tu fous des lamas drame il
n'y a pas de mépris dans la définition
du bonheur pourquoi tu acceptes
il ya pas que pour me toiture est pas ce
que tu veux faire plaisir aux gens du
drs que les gentils des eaux-vives ta
vie est-ce qu'ils subissent ce que tu
subis
[Musique]
je suis resté face à moi et je joue j'ai
décidé d'en sortir
comment j'ai juste compris
vous avez comment j'ai quitté ce ménage
je suis en train soit j'ai pris mon
passeport je suis allé le voir j'ai pris
un pied des passes
[Applaudissements]
georges colas il arrive quand j'avais 30
ans
avec les ophones
j'ai accepté de partir
je me suis dit je veux être heureuse
j'ai recommencé avec écrit ce livre que
j'ai donc voulu écrire pour dénoncer
gens vont me servir gfs un diplôme parce
que quand nous regarder dans mon
parcours académique il ya trois années
quatre années pendant lesquelles madame
était assise à la maison parce que
monsieur avait dit tu restes à la
distance et de maîtrise pour toi servir
du nom ici que l'hélium et vous ne savez
pas ce que c'est que d'avoir honte de
soi ne tient pas compte du regard des
autres il ne savait pas ce que c'est que
de se re sous l'emprise de ben ali fille
qui veut sur les du conditionnement
j'ai commencé à dire j'ai créé pour ses
talents des femmes de pouvoir avec cinq
branches et j'aime les femmes assez mais
j'aime les petites filles à se valoriser
parce que dans mon étape de chrysalide
j'ai commencé à m'aimer je me suis
pardonner
j'ai accepté mes échecs j'ai accepté que
je vois qu'à des assureurs et je vais
commencer à vivre
[Applaudissements]
connaissent pas c'est ma vie mon bonheur
est définie je sais ce qu il ne faut pas
heureuse je ne souffrais plus et je me
suis remarié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
contre un homme on ne les gagne comme
semaine attention il a su très bien
comme ça mais sa famille est ma fille
mon fils je me suis jamais franchie mais
je ne souffre plus à l'école de mon fils
souvent on laisse le pack propres murs
de mon mari est soit la bête du
bâtonnier du premier enfant à mon label
d'humanitude deuxième enfant ça me fout
la honte
mais c'est fini je ne souffre plus parce
que vous ne savez pas ma fille ils ne
savaient pas ma vie et c'est appréciable
ne s'est pas navigation aux critiques on
sent le sourire alors que dedans même
certains à votre bonheur et attention je
ne dis pas que des femmes mais je
m'adresse aussi aux hommes le gall soit
derrière comme ça non le faire
maintenant on va parler parce que ça
ne se dépeint ici affirmait à mesure ici
c'est pas forcément de la violence
physique c'est beaucoup plus que dans
les cas des femmes mais à des zombies ne
sont pas heureux mais qui sont là il
faudra définir son bonheur j'ai survécu
oui j'ai survécu à ce moment de ma vie
j'ai accepté de mourir j'ai accepté ces
débats d'inertie je me suis posé la
vraie question et j'ai assumé les ronces
je me dis ce soir comme survivre il
faudra voir c'est de mourir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]